non è facile nascere cieco
non è non è facile nascere 5 in una
città del sud non è facile vivere da
cieco nella periferia di una città del
sud
sono nata a Bari nel 1980 e Sin Dai
primi mesi di vita sono alta a vivere
Naturalmente con la mia famiglia a
quartiere San Paolo per l'appunto una
periferia di Bari
Bari non era Certamente quella che
conosciamo oggi ma un luogo in cui le
periferie erano totalmente disconnesse
dal tessuto urbano
oggi vi voglio raccontare che cosa ha
significato per me costruire la mia vita
dovendo imparare a conoscermi a sondare
i miei limiti ad accettarli e a tentare
di spostare leggermente più in là
partendo proprio da queste due
condizioni di fragilità
l'essere non vedente e crescere in una
città difficile in un quartiere
difficile
i miei genitori hanno scoperto che non
ci vedevo solo quando avevo due anni
e tolto un primo momento di come si può
dire di
assoluto disconnessione dalla realtà di
totale disconnessione della realtà di
sconvolgimento
hanno tentato di farmi crescere nel modo
migliore possibile che loro conoscevano
che loro immaginavano per me cioè come
tutti gli altri
voglio raccontarvi due episodi che forse
possono raccontare meglio questo
nei quartieri periferici Come alcuni di
voi sapranno ci sono dei posti degli
spazi che altri luoghi della città non
non hanno vale a dire quei grandi
giardini dei condomini
bene Io sono stato introdotto alla vita
scorrazzano proprio in uno di questi
condomini In uno di questi giardini
socializzando con i bambini che come me
crescevano lì certo non era facile per
un diverso quella che oggi chiamiamo
inclusione ma
mio padre
si era messo in testa che io dovevo fare
le cose che facevano gli altri stare con
gli altri costruire la mia vita come
facevano gli altri e così seri imposto
affinché io
giocassi con gli altri e un giorno c'era
una partita di calcio
nel campetto del nostro giardino
e mio padre mi butto nella mischia mi
disse Vai era un bambino molto piccolo
e un po' cadendo un po' colpendo o
essendo colpito dalla palla
cominciai la mia avventura di giocatore
i miei amichetti impararono ad
accettarmi e mi coinvolgevano nel loro
partite
e mi mandavano Addirittura in porta
Pensate un po' un po' Forse perché così
pensavano che far gol sarebbe stato più
facile
un po' perché in quei posti in quei
posti la
democrazia è sovrana Tutti devono andare
in porta e se ci pensate Questa è una
forma di inclusione sociale enorme di
assoluta non discriminazione Ecco
accertarsi questo accettarsi Questo è il
primo passo è stato il mio primo passo
accettare che si è diversi che certe
cose si possono fare e certe altre no
prendere consapevolezza dei propri
limiti e comprendere come spostarli
leggermente più in là
e questo non vale solamente per le
persone con disabilità ma penso che
valga per tutti
non è facile lo so tuttora io ve ne
parlo però
cerco di capire come posso
spostare più in là qualche limite che in
realtà ho
non è facile accettare queste difficoltà
questi limiti
È tuttora ci sono delle cose che cerco
di superare ma ci sono delle cose che
sono oggettive che è difficile da
sfidare ad esempio penso che per me sarà
una cosa che mi ha sempre fatto un po'
pensare che per me sarebbe stato
difficile quasi impossibile guidare
e quindi voi pensate un po' un ragazzo
che abitava in una periferia di una
città del sud negli anni 80 l'unico
luogo di aggregazione era il centro
andare in centro e come si andava in
centro solo con i mezzi pubblici quindi
la cosa era grave
perché con la macchina non sarei mai
potuto andare e poi Poi vedevo Supercar
e sognavo
e qualcuno forse un giorno
realizzerà questo sogno Se pensate al
progetto delle macchine a guida
assistita
un altro episodio che vi voglio
raccontare ma forse non è solamente un
episodio ma tanti momenti in cui mi
isolavo nel giardino sempre lo stesso
Giardino del mio condominio
e lì in quel giardino
mi rintanavo in un angolo isolato da cui
si accedeva attraverso una stradina
sterrata
mi sedevo su un muretto e mi perdevo nel
buio del cielo
io Ora vi racconto una semplice
percezione luminosa vedo se così si può
dire solo luce e ombre pian piano che il
tempo passa Purtroppo le luci sono
sempre meno le ombre sono sempre di più
per fortuna il mio spazio luminoso
interiore invece viaggia inversamente
proporzionale e inversamente
proporzionale a questo quindi va bene
così da adolescente mi chiudevo nel mio
angolo di giardino per fissare per
fissare l'universo la sua immensità e mi
sentivo cioè questa energia che mi
scorriva addosso che mi penetrava mi
compenetrava
e cominciamo a prendere consapevolezza
di quanto
queste le dimensioni che le grandezze di
questo universo fossero molto più grandi
di quelle di cui noi siamo abituati a
vivere Normalmente se pensiamo per
esempio al mondo a quanto la luce
impiega per arrivare sulla terra
dal sole o da altro pianeta queste
dimensioni sono totalmente superiori e
incommensurabilmente incomparabili con
quelle a cui siamo abituati solitamente
viene questo mi ha insegnato
l'importanza dell'altro da sé l'altro da
me di come ciò che ci circonda fa la
differenza
non sono io ho sbagliato ma il mondo che
mi accoglie che devo cercare di
riportare a me stesso
E se questo si adatta a me si ci
permette di vivere meglio
mi ha insegnato l'importanza degli altri
di come essi mi possono aiutare a
superare le difficoltà
e questo l'ho anche riassunti in
un'opera d'arte che ha avuto la fortuna
di contribuire a realizzare con una
amica artista Pamela Diamante che
abbiamo poi esposto anche al pack di
Milano alla nuvola di Fuksas a Roma
Oggi sono qui quindi a raccontarvi di
come compenetrandosi soltanto
profondamente dentro se stessi
cercando di comprendere i propri limiti
cercando di accettarli prendendo
consapevolezza di essi si può tentare un
cambiamento
e di costruire una vita positiva
nonostante le difficoltà una vita che
supera le difficoltà guardando oltre
quella luce
quando ero piccolo mio padre spesso mi
portava
all'aeroporto a vedere gli aerei alla
pista dell'aeroporto che era dietro casa
ai confini di questa vabbè era un po'
qualcosa di un po' pericoloso diciamo
così Però all'epoca si poteva ci si
poteva avvicinare anche le transex alle
recinzioni e quando vedevo percepivo
quelle ombre d'acciaio che mi passavano
sulla testa
io ero estasiato era un adolescente era
un adolescente cieco figlio di una
famiglia non ricca che viveva in un
posto sperduto di una periferia del
quartiere San Paolo Pensate un po' La
periferia di una periferia
nessuno avrebbe scommesso un euro che da
lì a pochi anni avrei cominciato a
prendere aerei su aerei ad aggirare il
mondo a rappresentare la mia università
da studente per
rappresentare le persone con disabilità
come me in convegni internazionali e
nessuno avrebbe scommesso che sarei
andato a lavorare a Bruxelles a livello
pieno disability forum per l'appunto o
all'unesco tante altre cose che qui non
vale la pena raccontare che non serve
raccontare
ho sfidato tanti ostacoli nella mia vita
e sono qui a dirvi che questo
che questo mondo è così pieno di cose
che parafrasando Amleto la nostra
fantasia Non può nemmeno immaginare
Dunque mai arrendersi sempre guardare
oltre lo sguardo rivolto sempre al
futuro il futuro c'è dal 2006 ha avuto
anche i ticchettii del
delle zampe dei miei cani guida coloro
che mi hanno accompagnato prima Dolly
ora Gemma che hanno costruito la mia
vita con più grande libertà e forse oggi
posso anche dire
che i miei occhi sono unici perché
viaggiano su quattro zampe
[Applauso]